حرب جديده قد تستعرض بين الولايات المتحده
والصين تستخدم فيها اصغر الاسلحه في
العالم الرقائق الالكترونيه واشباه
الموصلات التي باتت جزءا اساسيا في
تكنولوجيا السلاح الجديد
لابحاث الاسلحه النوويه تبعا للحكومه
الصينيه اشترى رقاقات كمبيوتر متطوره من
الولايات المتحده بشكل غير مباشر اكثر من
اثنتي عشر مره خلال سنتين ونصف السنه
العقده تكمن في ان عمليه الشراء غير
المباشر تجاوزت قيود تصدير الامريكيه
المفروضه منذ عقود والتي تهدف الى منع
استخدام اي من منتجات الولايات المتحده
لابحاث الاسلحه الذريه من قبل قوى خارجيه
وهو ما يفعله معهد الابحاث الذي اشترى
رقائقك مكونات لانظمه الحوسبه المخصصه
للاستهلاك الشخصي من بائعين في الصين
المعهد الذي يعرف باسم الاكاديميه الصينيه
للفيزياء الهندسيه من اوائل المؤسسات
الصينيه التي ادرجتها واشنطن على القائمه
السوداء بسبب ابحاثها النوويه واستخدامها
لاشباه الموصلات الامريكيه في تلك الابحاث
لتحليل البيانات وانشاء الخوارزميات
مخاوف وعبرت عنها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
في نوفمبر الماضي قائله ان الصين تسرع
قدراتها النوويه
البنتاجون قدر ان الجيش الصيني سيخزن
حوالي 1500 راس النووي بحلول 2035 بينما
العدد الحالي هو 400 ولا تكون المشكله في
السيطره على امتلاك تلك الرقائق في انه
يتم تصنيعها خارج الولايات المتحده ما
يصعب مهمه مراقبه الصادرات ووجهتها
النهائيه